you
[Music]
next up we have Nina from CMU talking
about data-driven algorithm design yeah
of course so I'll be talking about using
machine learning for data-driven
automated algorithm design and in
particular about some recent provable
grantees for this I think very exciting
area of data-driven or alwasy design
okay and my focus in the talk will be on
combinatorial problem so in discrete
structures the community algorithms or
discrete structures so the way I think
about it is like using machine learning
Alani theory to influence theory of
computing and algorithm design and
hopefully the corresponding application
areas okay and let me start with some
very high-level motivation for this line
of work so the classic way to design and
analyze algorithms for comunitaria
problems impose at the ovens that we
designed for a given problem will be
used to solve worst case instance isn't
the problem about which the algorithm
has absolutely no information at all ok
and so in this classy framework the kind
of performance guarantees we seek for
for our algorithm is that the algorithm
will succeed even for sorting the one
time worst case the instance of the
underlying algorithm problem ok and so
within this classic framework you know
well know there are some products that
are easy so for example if we are
concerned the running time is our major
performance measure we know there are
some problems that we teaching basic
undergraduate algorithms courses for
which we have optimal polynomial time
algorithms but I'll guarantee to output
the optimal solution in polynomial time
even worse case instances ok so there
are some brands that are either within
the classic framework but if but for
most problems within the classic
framework we do not have such strong
performance guarantees
ok so examples of hard problems include
clustering problem problems partitioning
problem subset selection problems in
fact actually most combinatorial
problems are kind of hard with in the
classic framework now one interesting
approach commonly used in practice for
had problems especially in cases when it
you need to solve not only one instance
of the underlying economy problem but
cases already to repeatedly solve
instances of the underlying algorithmic
problem so one kind of interesting
approach used in practiced over to solve
these hard problems is to use machine
learning and instances coming from the
given domain in order to learn an
algorithm but as well just in our type
of instances okay and this is very
natural idea of course because you know
in practice different math for a given
type of combinatorial problem different
methods or better in different settings
and also often we often have large
family of methods that we could choose
from so it's very natural to try to use
machine learning and instances of the
problem coming from our specific domain
to learn an algorithm but as well just
in our type of instances okay and indeed
this approach has a large history in
many applied communities including in
the AI community like Eric Horowitz
actually had some early or convenes also
in computational biology community
engage in a kind of AI based mechanism
design community so you know this idea
of using machine learning to learn
algorithms has been widely used many
different apply communities and actually
several breakthroughs in this areas have
come from its approach okay however
surprisingly to me until basically very
very recently when we knew very little
formally about this approach okay and so
my talk today my talk today I'll try to
survey some recent work but we've been
doing with my students and collaborators
in order to kind of provide former
grantee stories data-driven algorithm
selection so I'll discuss
there'll be left of course we're gonna
use this traditional learning
formalization or or online learning
formalizations and the actual meaning of
the grantees will depend on the
formalization and I've mentioned several
case studies but also I'll try to kind
of hint of what kind of more general
principles that arise by thinking about
these problems hopefully more broadly
applicable beyond specific specific
cases okay and because this is an I also
a lot of the people here in the audience
are AI and machine learning I just want
to point out obviously that this is very
connected to a bunch of very hot topics
in fly machine an e-business like hyper
parameter tuning auto ml meta learning
you know it of course this topic is very
late to those topics except think about
it about our set in being in
combinatorial settings and also we have
frugal guarantees as opposed to a lot of
these topics more applying ml without
guarantees okay so it's a kind of a
high-level overview and and this the
kind of structures my talk is as follows
I'll describe how we can think about
data-driven algorithm design or
selection as a distributional or
statistical learning problem I'll
mention a couple of case studies and
also point on general sample complexity
theorem between arises in this context
and I don't think I have a lot of time
to talk about online learning the online
learning formulation but I'm happy to
talk offline about details of that
formulation okay so I start with the
data-driven algorithm design is a
distribution or any problem but before
doing so let me just become just to be
concrete let me mention an example of a
problem that we might want to solve in a
data-driven approach okay this is a very
familiar problem to all of us it's
clustering we're doing a set of objects
like news articles web pages search he's
all tending to somehow cluster them into
natural groups as well as we can and
hold on to point out this is a perfect
example of a problem where we need to
repeatedly solve instances of a given
clustering problem right so for example
if you're if you are Google and if
you're using clustering two clusters
news articles then of course you're
gonna
cluster news articles every day in fact
many times a day so this is a perfect
example of a prom but we need to solve
it
so we can try to hop through the data
even approach okay and of course like
formally like what type of clustering
technique would be using we can either
use objective based clustering Christ
where we pick a specific objective
function like that came in subjected the
comedian objective or the and okay
Center objective and try to optimize it
on a given input set of data points so
this is one formulation you can try to
use and of course we all know that is
for example all of these specific
objective like optimizing camis
optimizing comedian and so on is np-hard
so it makes sense to try to the data
didn't approach to kind of learn the
good algorithm for our type of data
because there is no universal efficient
algorithm that works all on worst-case
the instances
okay so objective based clustering is a
good application of it a that even
approach but if you think about it also
kind of the more machine learning
formulation where somehow we assume that
there is a hidden ground truth and you
are trying to get close to it kind of
unsupervised learning or matching the
ground truth version of the clustering
problem also makes sense in visit a
different approach so either of these
formulations can be casted as they tell
people I was in design
ok so now with this example now we can
go and describe the how we can think
about algorithm selection is a
distributional learning problem and of
course this will be super familiar to
the machine only people audience a
machine learning people here in the
audience so it's very natural so what we
do we fix an algorithmic problem it want
to solve like facility location or
clustering or your favor coming out to
your problem when we fix a large family
of algorithms for our problem and this
can be a parameterised if any familiar
of algorithms right because it might
have various modules analogy the family
might have various modules with knobs
that might add true tune right and the
fix is family of algorithms because we
either know it works well in practice or
maybe because you have analytical
reasons to believe it might be good for
our type of data
remember what we do we take a sample of
typically instances of our problem
coming from our domain and technically
we assume that this sample of typical
instances is an iid sample of typically
instances from some an underlying
distribution of our instances and to use
a sample of typical isn't is to come up
with a new
an algorithm that will we hope or I want
to prove it as well a new instance is
coming from the same underlying source
okay so for example and so by the way
I'm using this pictorial it but you know
this is hopefully very clear so for
example if our drinks a facility
location what'll be typical instance is
well a typical week or the first time
could be an input graph first input
graph a second sample would be a second
input graph and so on right or if we are
doing clustering for trying to learn the
clustering algorithm say for clustered
documents without what our are our
typical instances well me instance the
first instance could be a first set of
documents a second instance would be a
second set of documents and so on and
decider can be on labeled if we're
trying to maybe do say objective based
clustering like hey means clustering or
they can be labeled if you are trying to
match ground off so for example if I'm
trying to cluster the document says are
these clustering documents and of course
I need for the training examples grant
of blessings okay and so basically based
not be set up typically instance is that
we want to do we want to come up with an
algorithm that performs well that you
can prove that performs well or new
random instances coming from the same
underlying distribution of typical
instance is the training set and of
course we now know that we can build on
tools from statistical learning theory
to kind of analyze sample complexity
questions in this framework meaning to
analyze how large the set of typical
instances be in order to guarantee but
if we output an algorithm that does well
about the training set of typical East
and sees that algorithm will also do
well no new instances it is not coming
from the same source but it never seen
the Train Set can do of course we also
know from statistical learning theory
but in order to analyze it sample
complexity results for example in order
to get uniform convergence and
complexity results what we need to be
able to understand he's a kind of the
interesting dimension or the interesting
complexity of the induced class of
functions by the familiar barbarisms and
our performance measure at hand okay so
all we need to do is to analyze up to
the dimension order edema complexity of
this induced class of functions and then
of course that's a key quantity now
typically from convergence balance okay
now what's interesting in this new
domain and defending it's exciting from
Aulani theory point of view is that the
functions that appear in these settings
wants to start learning algorithms
because our hypothesis space is a space
of algorithms now we get very
interesting structure something
particular because we are learning
algorithms for combinatorial problems we
essentially and our corresponding angles
have combinatorial modules we get in
situations where if we slightly change
the parameters you can get drastically
different outputs so kind of the
corresponding cost functions have sharp
discontinuities and so it's kind of
interesting to try to analyze notions of
dimensions in be scenarios okay so that
kind of outside the what makes these
problems different from all classic
statistical learning theory okay and do
see a couple of examples of this rhombus
ad by specific types of functions the
prm's are the various applications who
looked at okay cool and so this is the
statistical learning from I was actually
point up at least thinking about
algorithm design or as a distribution I
mean problem was actually introduced in
a paper by teen rap garden in rishi
gupta his promise to deletion gupta in a
paper with appear in itcs venice icon
and they proposed the model in of
antagonism selection is a special
learning problem and then also over
analyzed parametrized families for
greedy algorithms for subset selection
problems like knapsack problems in that
work okay and I thought actually found
that paper fascinating I'm surprised
nobody has written such a paper out here
because it's very natural and I think
it's very powerful as well and after
what we with my students and
collaborators we followed up on it and
we analyzed new algorithm classes for a
variety of combinatorial problems okay
and they're just going to quickly
mention some of them and then I'm gonna
go into details of a couple of em okay
so for example in our first paper on the
topic we looked at in the context of
clustering problems
we looked at parametrized linkage
procedures for clustering followed by
some say of a fixed type of post
processing okay
also in a also for clustering in a new
leaf shape last year who looked at
infinite families of Floyd's method the
particular parameterize symmetries of
Lloyd's method so learn to initialize
the Lloyd's method okay
more recently with some colleagues from
computational biology at CMU we looked
at parameterize dynamic programming
procedures for solving alignment
problems in competition biology like
sequence alignment so these are some
types of cognitive problems we looked at
well so loopy original paper it's a very
different type of family of algorithms
so for example if you are trying to
solve partitioning problems it can be
written as integer quadratic programs
like Mark Scott we looked at
parametrized families we looked at
families of arms are reduced semi
definite programming followed by some
sort of parametrized rounding and again
learned how to round for our types of
instances in all obvious examples of
type even so far actually by design to
go back to your question we are going to
look at there by design in polynomial
time and that I'm trying to learn is an
algorithm that has good solution quality
like it has a good value of Max cart or
cluster documents well or maybe aligns
the sequence is well okay but we also
have looked at types of problems where
like for example looked at solving mixed
integer programs by you a via branch and
bound which is a type of technique while
using a I and O R and here we seldom see
the algorithm simply family solve the
problem to optimality but they might
take a long time and so we're trying to
optimize for his running time so the
solution quality for the algorithm is
running time I naught okay
and we also looked very related in to
attack techniques also appear in kind of
in the context of automatic mechanism
design for multi buyer multi-item
scenarios and again we here look at the
families of mechanisms like parameters
ECG auction posted prices and so on and
here we are also optimizing for is
revenue so like the the revenue really
the solution qualities of is families of
procedures okay and so it turns out that
you after looking at all of these some
general patterns emerge and I'm going to
tell you a little bit about those
but before doing so just to be concrete
and to have a concrete example in mind
to think about and to give you a simple
example of a family of parameterize
algorithms for clustering problems okay
so when I so in order to take a
data-driven approach for clustering
problems the very first thing we want to
do is to put down of course a family of
algorithms and here is a simple family
of average that we looked at both
because it's kind of widely used in
practice and also because it has some
nice analytical properties the data is
extremely nice like stable type of
instances it's known from a fury from
like beyond of kiss analysis branch if
you love computing ok so if the family
values as follows is the extremely
simple we have two stages each challenge
has two stages we first use a bottom-up
linkage procedure to greedy procedure to
hook up the data into a hierarchy to
create a cluster 3 and then we just do a
fixed post processing on these 3 for
example you can do dynamic programming
to extract the best k-means clustering
or we might just output the cluster
hindus by the last game our G's or just
my top of the hierarchy to the user and
the user can look at it ok
and of course and so just to remind you
what does it mean bottom-up
collaborative linkage procedures what we
do is we start with pointing there are
little aver on little cluster and then
we repeatedly merge the two closest
clusters ok and of course different
definitions of closest only two
different algorithms so for example here
different definition of clauses between
pairs of between subsets of points in
two different algorithms so here is an
example of a classic algorithm we teach
not basic undergrad a machinima courses
single linkage right or define the
distance between two subsets a and B to
be the minimum distance between the
points in the two subsets so here I'm
assuming the distance between point is
fixed and so single link is defined this
and if it the tree-tops has to be the
minimum distance between points the
corresponding subset but another classic
algorithm complete linkage
defines the distance between the two
subsets to be the maximum distance
between the points in the corresponding
subset right and so you can even imagine
now getting coming up with an infinite
family of linkage procedures because we
might want to interpolate between these
based criteria right and so for example
here is an example of a family but you
looked at in our work some that I call
alpha weighting linkage right now there
is a hidden there is a parameter alpha
but I can hope to tune for my data and I
define the distance between two subsidy
to be 1 minus alpha times the distance
given by single linkage plus alpha times
the distance given by a complete linkage
ok so this is a concrete example of
artists alpha by D linkage Sherman is a
concrete example of a parametrized
symmetry of algorithms for a
combinatorial formula toriel brahmin
clustering i think we can now start
start to understand what's the SU
dimension of assemblies of algorithms is
and by the way so yeah what dimension is
just the the most natural extension of
VC dimension to your valid functions I'm
not gonna be finally precisely but all
you need to know okay and so for this
specific family of algorithms I'm gonna
quickly show you that the SU dimension
is only log n or n is an upper bound on
the number of points in the in any input
instance but I might have to solve and
because of dimension is log n actually
can also show that actually if you are
given a set of typical instances of set
as a training set of typical instances
of clustering problems we can find the
best algorithm from this family in
polynomial time okay so you can do not
know what in machine learning theory
Tommy can you solve erm in polynomial
time efficiently for this simple family
of clustering procedures okay and like
like in any other community or your
problems kind of the the challenge here
is is really because the vase as I
mentioned because of this combinatorial
kind of type of output it can be nice
you can be in a situation that if you
slightly change on far this can lead to
a kind of to a change early on in the
decision made by the linkage procedure
which one can snowball and produce a
much larger change later on so in other
words if it's like each Intel so you can
get a totally different output
so this is really the difficulty here
but you know what we in order to analyze
me in order to what we can show is that
this doesn't happen too often dreams
okay so these not leads to good
dimension bounds
I mean particular what we can show is
that here's the key fact that kind of
any implies that two dimension is only
logarithmic in an or what n is an upper
bound on the number of points in the
input instance so the fact is as follows
it's basically what it shows is kind of
but the corresponding cost function is
piecewise constant okay so what does it
mean well for any given value of alpha
when you run alpha by D linkage kind of
Yahoo is not going to make a sequence of
decision and you're going to create a
specific linkage tree now of course if I
change alpha I'm gonna get a different
tree but what this fact here says that
if I've areata from say 0 to 1 and if I
fix an instance a clustering instance
event point and when I vary the
parameter alpha from 0 to 1 there at
most n to the 8th switching point were
the three produce hundreds in instance
changes and then of course which then
implies that no matter what is your cost
function the top distance the ground
true for cami's cost and so on the
corresponding cost function his
piecewise constant with n to the eight
pieces okay which turns out to be very
nice because any plighted to dimension
is only log n ok and let me just quickly
give you a high-level idea of how this
that has proven this is not hard at all
in this specific case so the key idea is
as follows so if you fix a clustering
instance and let's even fix alpha which
is the parameter mile for whittling each
procedure and let's imagine at at some
point in the algorithm the algorithm has
to decide should it merge to the blob
and 1 and then 2 or should it merge the
blob and three and then four right now
the decision here depends on eight
points because if I denote by P and Q to
be the farthest point in and one and and
to don't give the distance given by
completing each and P Prime and Q prime
to be the closest point in N 1 and n 2
and if I do you know by R and s to be
the farthest point in n 3 and then 4 and
R Prime and is trying to be the closest
point in and 3 and then for the decision
of whether to merge the first two blobs
and 1 and then 2 versus n 3 and n 4
really depends
which of these two quantities alpha
times the distance between P and Q plus
or minus alpha times the distance
between P Prime and Q prime or alpha
times distance between R and s plus 1
alpha times the distance between R Prime
and s prime is smaller and bigger and if
think about it like a critical point
where the behavior of the Amazon switch
is really at the moment where B's we
have an equality here right buddy
so in other words a critical point
really happens at a root of a linear
equality like me so the linear equality
is given by 8 points but of course I
only have n to be 8 such kind of linear
equalities I can put down because I have
this is the number of eight supers and
out of n points okay so this basically
proves that kind of at a high level it's
the key idea for proving but for this
specific simple linkage family if I fix
alpha so if I fix the instance the
clustering instance and very alpha I can
only get n to the 8th cluster in trees
produced 10 minutes that's perfect and
now once the heavy structure a result I
can immediately prove that su dimension
bounds right this is here what I showed
you what happens if I fix the instance
and very alpha I showed you what happens
if the the corresponding cost function
but of course when you compute that
pseudo dimensionally care about not only
about the behavior of the Allan stam
you're not given instance but they kind
of care about how many instances can you
kind of kind of shattering crisis how
many things can you know how many senses
can you really get an exponential number
of behavior so I decide to care about
and so now I have to think about what
happens with high-five M instances and
clustering instances and what I know the
immediate key the key defect in the
previous bound me Utley implies if I
have M clustering instances as I vary
alpha I can only get like M times n to
the power of 8 patterns for your studies
and plastering instances and I'll just
use the definition of so dementia Roth
is speaking to then just compute what
the pursue dimension is because the true
dimension will be the largest and for
which an exponential number of patterns
is achievable okay and so all I have to
do
just call for the largest time for which
I can achieve an exponential number of
patterns so that means I have to solve
this inequality over here the largest
time for which 2 to the M is upper
bounded by M times n to the 8th and so
this one immediately implies that the
two dimension is only log n okay for
this simple example here by the way I
don't have this on my slides you might
ask do you gain anything in practice
before doing this interpolation it turns
out of it actually we can so I had the
master to the experiment it turns out
that you know even on M needs to buy
overall you wanna try to class the
substance of a mist actually can gain a
little bit by tuning the parameter alpha
here in the Alpha we can engage like a
free person so not a lot but you still
gain a 3% and value cricket artificial
example sorry gain a lot okay but here
is another family also staying with
clustering Corey gain a lot in practice
oh sorry actually before going for let
me just finish off like was I just
showed you is that the two dimension of
this family of alpha we dealing each
procedure is log n only a Big O of log n
actually by the way we can also show
it's really big setup log n one of my
former students had a lower bound
showing that and moreover you can also
implement you can also you solve the
corresponding erm problem in polynomial
time so if I give you a set of instances
of typical instances you can find the
best answer from the family in
polynomial time one kind of more
inefficient way to did best in
polynomial time is to given every input
instance you correspond you compute a
corresponding alpha integral of the
instance you take all the corresponds
the union of all those critical points
and try to take the best of at the on
average over the sample but works you
can even make it more efficient and one
of my students did that and ran
experiments with it and as I mentioned
by doing this on a Miss for instance we
get a three percent improvement over
either single or complete linkage and
also on some cdata that we can do even
better okay but here is actually also
and this is by the way I'm not saying
but this is they kind of work for me it
was only a toy example try to understand
this space of like how do you analyze
later the knob doesn't design from a
Loni fury you point of you know but we
also done experiments just for fun you
know I'm not advocating it as the
to use only Thai to date a different
class but actually one one one want
another family or you can slightly
improve on it you can do even a little
bit better experimental in this actually
can be also of interest experimental II
in addition to being of interest
theoretically is one where you are not
tuning only the Alpha you are not only
in tuning times the linkage procedure
but you are also doing the distance
function okay and in particular for
certain types of data you might have
very different types of distance
information so for example if you have
captioned images you of course you can
use some distance function based on the
pixel information of the image but you
know I also have a very different
distance function based on the captions
right and you can try to told to mix
between those or similarly for
handwritten digits you know for example
for the classic Omniglot data set is
used in meta-learning
you have both the pixel information but
you also have strobe data about how the
characters are written and so this can
provide very complimentary type of
distance information and so now we can
put down kind of an infinite family of
matrix of a matrix or distance functions
where you interpolate now say linearly
between this say for now to base
distance functions D 0 and E 1 and so we
can now try to tune also this better
parameter related to the distance
function okay so you can for example get
now just to be concrete if I can now try
to get a family of alphabet away linkage
procedure what I use alpha the parameter
alpha to interpolate between the linkage
criteria single and compelling hitch and
I use a tram eater beta to kind of tune
the distance function to interpolate
between two fixed base distance
functions between pairs of points okay
and I'll call this alphabet away T
linkage and you can again try to analyze
what the true dimension of is family of
algorithms and of course try to find the
best kind of algorithm probably family
for your type of data and I'm not gonna
go for the details here but tons of it
again because we can still show here
that and adapt to dimension of assembly
of procedures alphabet weight linkage
procedure is log and now the structure
result is a little bit it's feel simple
but in
just tiny be more complicated so to
prove it a two-dimensional alphabet I
would have introduced log n what you
have to show is again something about a
structure the dual function so I fix an
instance vary the parameters alpha beta
and I can show that I can partition the
space the parameter space with a number
of linear and quadratic equations so so
but for any two parameters in the same
region I get the same cluster
pre-produced okay and once I have is and
I can again do the SU dimension argument
on the top of this okay and I'm not
gonna go food how many more minutes do I
have - okay so much given beaters here
but they uh you have to look at the
structure the problem to put this back
okay but actually before jumping to the
next higher level story on to actually
mention but these actual bees tuning
alpha and better actually did have an
impact on the real world real data for
example if done experiments on Omniglot
which is a classic dataset used for meta
learning these days and here we show
that if you interpolate between distance
functions given by features obtained
from CNN embeddings on a related data
sets am is on the M nice to end on a
mist if interpolate between kind of
distance function being by CNN weddings
convulsion narrative embedding and the
strobe the hell design distance function
which uses a stroke information you can
actually get a big improvement like
about a nine percent improvement in
accuracy so here it makes a difference
kind of shows the true distance
functions are that are very
complementary and actually my students
did this experiment specifically for
researchers okay but I can use a ward
deep learning here somewhere because I'm
using CN anybody
I'm not sure that's MIT be but but it's
nice to see that actually that improving
practice I was pleased about okay
now going back to the high-level story
it tells of it we look as I mentioned
look at many different other types of
problems like we look for example
partitioning probabilities in integer
quadratic programs and here we look at
parametrized symmetries of procedures or
reduced semi definite programming
relaxation followed by like randomized
rounding and because parameterize
rounding not going for the details the
key point to observe here is again is it
like the one to proved up to dimension
bounds that you have to show
that if we fix an instance and vary the
parameters of the underlying algorithm
family the corresponding function is
piecewise structure so in particular
here is piecewise inversely quadratic
with only NPCs waves what happens here
related structure appears on we do
mechanism design so for example if we
look at I so just to be complete posted
price mechanisms in cases what he has
multi by the multi item scenarios and
now we have a parameter for each posting
price of my set on each of the items and
again what arises here is that kind of
the corresponding if I fix an instance
or a set of bidders and their values for
the substance of the items if I vary the
price is the corresponding revenue
function is piecewise linear where each
of the pieces on in the parameter space
is given by linear separator
intersection of linear separators okay
so this is kind of the key because the
kid his order to use to converge to
damage Monte net worth and so motivated
by this now when most isn't or to arouse
a more general theorem trying to kind of
decouple the structure of the problem
from what we need to get statistical
kind of two dimension bounds
and here's the abstraction so what to
really care about is computing the su
dimension of a function class
parametrized by alpha which functions
parameterize by alpha and takes the
different instances of the problem like
so it clustering a set of a time to
class okay
and so we show time to bondage to
dimensions such a function class in all
of these proofs we take advantage of the
structure on the dual class of functions
now a function that your class is
parameterized by an instance of the
problem and takes in the inputs possible
parameters values and what we showed in
all of these domains is that these dual
functions are piecewise structured and
what do you mean by piece.i structure
for every function that in the dual
looks IDs I can basically partition the
parameter space by using functions from
a well behaved function class F such as
inside each of a species like here the
corresponding cost function is identical
to one another to a function G coming
from another function class capital G
and that we are able to show is that
basically we can give a Bandhan de su
dimension of the original function was
at a really care about where the
function the class is parameterize by
alpha
as a function of the kind of the the
niceness of these dual functions and
again the niceness here is these dual
functions are piecewise structure but
the pieces are defined by functions
function class f and the inside is the
piece I am identical to a function G
from a function class G and you can put
a bond and the Basu dimension at the
final function because I care about is a
function of the niceness of his function
classes f energy a function of the
Boundary functions and the functions the
the nice is the function inside the
business okay and one kind of cool cell
it appears here is not really the VC
dimension of post function classifies
the VC dimension of the dual of those
function classes and there are readers
for vet they can step out of line okay
and just I have I guess 0 minutes left I
just want to mention butts up I talked
about this traditional learning you can
also ask questions how about online
learning think about how is in selection
is an online learning problem what the
instances are not given to your patron
that they come one by one and you kind
of want to achieve no regret and because
as I already mention I have sharp
discontinuities if you are as many
people here online learning expert in
the audience you know but once we have
sharp discontinuities it's impossible to
achieve no regret and so we had a paper
with my students and in focus wasn't 18
and the follow-up paperwork identify
sufficient conditions for cheating now
regret once we are doing online learning
of piecewise if she's functions and then
shove at these conditions hold in many
of these algorithm configuration or I
was in online I was in selections
problem ok and again I have to talk
about this offline that the condition is
just the zombies piecewise functions
just dispersion roughly speaking we just
required the discontinuities of the
corresponding cost function don't
concentrate too much back with burst and
you can put formal definitions around
attend again I'm happy to talk of lines
okay but I guess just to summarize so I
think this is a very interesting area
research to think about algorithm design
as a learning problem either
distributional any problem or or
statistical and promote my learning
problem and you can provide from former
guarantees and also from Aulani theory
point of view the the structure to arise
in the settings I think are very
interesting and kind of help us push the
boundaries of lucky theory as well which
is always very exciting so
[Applause]
you stay in today - n square I think we
have a lower bound to the people so we
can discuss so yeah so it should the
lower bomber - no it's n to the thief we
can show an instance for answers a thief
you can haven't we haven't yet you
continue through here we don't know if
there's a gap between n to the fifth and
then to the X now that being said one of
the experiments are my students have
dined here what do you never get into
the FIFA teen so he's very convoluted
and I can anything that you've tried
it's all linear e 9 so that while can
even tune the parameters because
N squared
let's talk about it okay next up we have
classes from MIT so the so I'm going to
talk about machine learning bias and how
to use circuit statistics to reduce the
bias and in particular so the motivation
of this talk is that oftentimes in data
science problems you work with the data
set and oftentimes collecting that data
set so there's a selection bias in
collecting your data which makes the
training set that you use to train your
models different than the test set the
conditions that your model is going to
be facing in the future and in
particular training on a biased data set
will introduce bias in your predictions
so the goal of the talk is to decrease
this bias using censored and truncated
statistics which refers to to an area in
statistics that is trying to do
inference given Turk area or sense of
samples
truncated samples refer to the situation
where samples falling outside of an
observation window are not observed and
their count is also not known censoring
means you at least have the count of how
many data for
outside of your observation window and
of course this can happen for many
reasons these types of phenomena
possibly your measuring devices your
measurement devices get saturated
outside of a band of measurement when
they get such ready to get bad readings
and these are not reliable so that's a
case of censoring you know you know how
many measurements are reliable in and
you also know how many aren't or you
know could arise from but experiment
design or it could come from situations
where ethical or other legal
considerations preclude you from using
some data points in your inference so
let me give a couple of motivating
examples to the you know that show what
may go wrong if you have bias in your
data so the first one is a you know well
discussed question in econometrics since
the fifties that has to do with relating
IQ training and education to earnings of
people so several works in the 50s and
60s try to understand this model by
collecting data and they did what you
think is the right thing so they
surveyed families whose income is one
point five times the poverty level and
the collected data were the covariates
correspond to the IQ training education
and a bunch of other features of
individuals for example belonging to
unions etc and the you know the response
variables were earnings for those
individuals and and they tried to fit a
model in particular the they tried to
fit linear models to their data and the
issue that you know might appear to be
important is that threshold in your data
collection to families whose income is
one point below threshold may actually
introduce bias in which features you
think are important for income and in
particular letter works debunked the
results of prior work showing for
example that besides education
occupational training and IQ are
actually important in earnings where
previous work found that most education
is important for earnings okay so for
our work who did not take into account
the threshold incorrect conclusions
about what is important for earnings so
to maybe fill the issue more viscerally
here is a different example so suppose I
instead of doing i q-- versus income
imagine i try to understand the
importance of height to being a good
basketball player and imagine that
because i'm i'm being lazy in my data
collection instead of serving the whole
population which is of course hard i
instead decide to download the NBA data
to do that so it's quite possible that
if i tried to fit a model on the NBA
data i may conclude that height is
actually neutral or even negatively
correlated to basketball performance but
that incorrect conclusion comes from the
fact that i was lazy and downloaded NBA
the NBA data as opposed to serving the
whole population and the mental picture
i want you to have while i'm going
through my slides is this that for
example in vanilla linear regression we
assume that the world is a perturbation
around the line but if you went and
first of all did the the data say you
only observe say this is wise basketball
performance and x's height you know it
could be that the world is linear around
some you know like a perturbation of a
line but imagine that i went and
downloaded and be a data which in
particular means that i only look at
people who have good basketball
performance
above a threshold now it's quite likely
that if I try to fit a line for on that
data this lines looks much more
plausible for this data set than this
line okay
eyes here independent of excise I think
if this is additive noise say but that's
just an example but but you know like
our standard like this like least
squares regression is a good estimator
for a world that is where the response
variable is just theta times X plus some
zero mean noise but Gaussian noise as
long as you choose that X's independence
or even a conservative weight if you
choose it but you need to suppose that
this constant you only estimate them is
now using this otherwise exited each is
it then oh yeah so you're asking what
happens if I try gate based on the next
I'll get to an example like in the in
the next slide like so yeah so here I'm
talking about white allocation there is
also X on occasion that's also an
important problem I'll get to that in a
sec but as far as Y truncation is
concerned we see here that I believe the
the way my my my believed line turns is
because you know like this data point
should not be mean this is a short guy
who happens to be a good basketball
player because of noise so he makes it
into NBA and he makes me believe that
short guys are good basketball players
okay but that was a result of the noise
which make made that guy enter into my
data set so coming to the X on occasion
a well discussed phenomenon observed
recently with gender classifiers is that
while
gender classifiers trained on Internet
data are really good in predicting
genders of basically light skin tone
people that can be very bad in people
who are not as much represented in the
data set
so in particular several of gender
classifiers you know from Microsoft
Facebook etc were really bad were pretty
bad in darker female gender prediction
and the explanation that has been
offered for why this happens is that
internet data has much more male
Caucasian lighter skin tone people and
for this reason when you train on the
data set you pay less attention to other
people and when you then go and test the
gender classifier in a particular sub
population you may actually get bad
performance and that's an example where
you have some turkey Asian in the X in
the in the in the covariate and which
leads to you not paying enough attention
to some subpopulations so what I want to
do is I want to see how ideas from track
ad statistics can be used to fight these
kinds of biases from entering your
predictions when you train on bias data
sets and I want to give a flavor of some
of the models and the work that I've
done with several collaborators and I
will center around three problems so one
pertains to the truncation of the Y
variable another truncation of the X
variable and then the third one is going
to be an unsupervised learning setting
so problem number one that I want to
consider is the is a following scenario
and that that is supposed to capture
situations like IQ versus earning and
height versus basketball performance so
I want to imagine that the factory that
produces my training data is the
following data factory so there it's
quite possible that you're this is not I
mean the main issue there is not
truncation it's because maybe this is
also the church this is also the test
dataset the tape that you know so the
point is you're doing this is a good so
you're doing well on the like you know
the training and maybe the training and
yes they are both have underrepresented
yeah so if if the training dataset is
representative of the test dataset then
you know when you're doing a good job
that there's no track there's no
truncation that bias is your predictor
yeah that's that's not a matter of
truncation
so yeah so the first problem that
pertains to truncation on the y-axis is
assumes the world is produced the
training set is produced by the
following data Factory so first you
sample X's from some underlying
population of X's then a response is
computing for every X the response is a
parametric function plus noise noise
could also come from a parametric
distribution and then so
up until this point this is the
classical supervised learning situation
where you have iid data training
distribution is the same as the test
distribution in life is good what is
different here is that then you look at
the Y and you decide whether or not to
include it in the training set so you
look at the Y so for example you look
whether this guy's a good basketball
player and if it's a good basketball
player you put him in the NBA data
otherwise you remove you you just throw
that sample in the trash okay and for
this scenario we'll assume that I know
this truncation Phi okay and it could be
probabilistic guess what I don't know is
a Donald D I don't know the base
distribution that samples humans I don't
know the mechanism that relates humans
features to have good basketball players
they are and I don't know the noise
model but I didn't know Phi because Phi
in some sense I I control so I chose to
download the NBA data or in the IQ vs.
earning example I chose to go and focus
in that particular neighborhood and do
my survey there okay so just to see
whether that model captures the scenario
of linear track aided linear regression
so in that case the model is a line the
noise is Gaussian and my truncation is
just deterministic it's a threshold
ngahuia a certain threshold so the goal
given training data produced by this
Factory okay the goal is to recover the
underlying ferrah the underlying
parameters that determine the mechanism
so the results that we have with good
luck is Jameson's orbit our keys and
with foundry Elias was here Suchitra and
Manolis on Pataki's of two kinds so it's
a general framework that allows you to
learn
models in these kinds of scenarios and
also this is a general adjective based
framework which you can ship to a GPU
and and try to recover there's-- now
that general framework if you restrict
in truncated linear regression or a
truncated probit or logistic regression
setting it will give you an - and
guarantees about recovery of the
underlying parameters so it's a
framework that can be used either for a
well-behaved setting where you can get
end-to-end guarantees or it can be used
in an arbitrary setting is an SGD based
framework that you can run but of course
if you have a neural network here you
will lose the end-to-end guarantees but
you can at least run your algorithm ok
so just to compare our results with
prior work so there is a long line of
research in econometrics statistics and
statistics on truncated or censored
regression either linear or probate and
logistic and the technical bottlenecks
in that work are of two kinds first and
this technical problem issues arise in
high dimensional settings the first one
is the algorithms that are used are
inefficient but and importantly the the
converging traits of the methods have
bad dependencies on the dimension here
you get this one over root n rates that
you expect or maximum likelihood
but the dependence of the rate in the
dimension is not well understood and so
what we get is we get optimal rates
namely the same rates that you get for
on truncated regression we get efficient
algorithms and we allow arbitrary
truncation sets that don't need to be
thresholds they can be basically any
measurable set
dependence on the on the threshold in
function the truncation function must be
something yeah so the selection function
the Phi function can be any measurable
function to get these rates you need two
things so one is the standard thing you
need for linear regression which is that
covereth the empirical covariance matrix
of your x i's has singular values that
are lower bounded this is the standard
thing you need for linear regression
what the extra assumption you need for
truncated irrigation is that the
threshold thing that's not basically
obliterate all your data that every like
the average x i has a constant
probability of not being obliterated by
the RS holding so as long as you have
some you know one percent on average
probability of making it into the
training set you get these guarantees so
I wanted to offer you a give a sense of
the techniques of and these are sort of
representative oh yeah yeah you're
assuming that the sweat fraction is
getting truncated here because you're
getting an end here so and is the number
oh and I'm truncated and is the number
of successful data points so how many
people were surveyed in that
neighborhood depends on this epsilon
what is the probability that a year the
the diffraction of
the probability that an average data
point is yes so that's I mean we assume
it's a constant and it's in the order
notation yeah yeah so let's assume that
every data point has a 1% probability of
making it into your observation window
that suffices it's not you can get
wicked conditions but let's say that
it's X I has a decent decent probability
of making it into the training set
before you see the way correct yeah so
like like if you look at this picture
here so say my threshold is here I want
that any X has a decent probability of
making it into the 1 say 1% probability
of making it in here
I don't need for every X but in for the
average X it could be as I said it could
be a miserable function but I need a
value truncation function is just
offensive to remove all the points in
the middle row yeah look at neighborhood
where incomes fall in a band right so
now I need that the average human has a
decent probability of you know living in
that neighborhood lucky like me you know
right so let me get a sense of the
techniques and and these are
representative what what's going on with
this line of work so I have this model
for how my training set is produced and
I have to ask I want to do maximum
likelihood and I want to ask what is the
density of my training set so the
density of my training set is a point X
Y the density is something like it has
to be sampled here you know half the
sample so I'm going to restrict my
attention not to like a very basic
linear regression model okay so you have
a line you have Gaussian normal 0 1 so
the density of the training set is this
density times the Gaussian density times
the probability that Y isn't truncated
and what makes this density hard is that
also have to normalize it so there is
some normalizing Z so some partition
function but the density of my training
set has these three components and the
normalizing factor function and what I
want to do is I want to do population
log likelihood on this model to recover
in this very simple setting I only want
to recover theta
so the log likelihood the population or
likely is an expectation of the you know
the true model theta star this density
with the true the star of the logarithm
of all these guys minus logarithm of the
partition function now the partition
function of course depends on theta so
it depends on theta star here now so the
the obvious issue that arises is that
first so to do likelihood over here so
we don't know D we don't know the you
know the distribution D and but even if
we did we would have to compute this
partition function and that is hard
that's difficult
so but you know the saving grace here is
that even though you cannot compute the
likelihood you cannot compute the
gradient you can still get a stochastic
gradient you can still get a random
variable whose expectation is the
gradient of this function without
needing to know D and without having to
compute the partition function okay so
in particular the it's not hard to see
that the gradient of this population log
likely function becomes the difference
of two expectations and that's an exact
equality and that's not very hard to see
so the gradient of this log likelihood
is the difference of two expectations
one expectation is taken with respect to
the true model Peter star of this
expression the other expectation is with
respect to the theta where I'm trying to
compute the gradient so in particular if
I want to get rights of the gradient so
so the gradient gets rid of this guy
that I don't know the gradient makes
this you know gives me this term the
gradient of this guy gives me this turn
and the claim and that's not hard to see
is that the gradient of this guy with
respect to Farrah's or C depends on
theta is just this expectation okay
that's that's not hard to see and that's
very standard that's the gradient of the
partition function is an expectation
okay so in particular the gradient of
the whole thing is the difference of two
expectations one expectation is of this
variable with respect to a sample from
the true model and the other expectation
is of the same function but on a sample
from the model for the particular theta
where I'm computing the gradient so yeah
so I want to do stochastic gradient
descent using this observation
and so the you better train right this
is assuming you I mean this is coming
from the truth year that's right because
this D theta train is a distribution of
XY pairs so to sing like this you
actually need to use D of X okay no I
have have true samples right so I can
click one of my training set one of my
training samples is rather already a
sample from this model I later train
right that's a function of theta star
correct and your oh I see so that's the
truth this is the truth this is the fake
and I have to simulate a fake together
to get this other term but but but but
you know this simulation has to be
successful and because of the training
because of the of the truncation that's
not to be taken for granted so I have to
be very careful where I'm doing
stochastic gradient descent if I go to
feathers that are very far away from
theta star it's possible that every so
I'm gonna simulate this model doing
rejection sampling so I'm gonna pick an
X and then I'm gonna run it through my
my model and then you know I'll see if
it successfully makes it into the
observation window if the process fails
over and over again I won't be able to
simulate that sample so better make sure
that my stochastic gradient doesn't
wander too far away in space and that it
successfully and at the end that's
sampling that rejection sampling
succeeds and the other thing that I need
is I need to have strong convexity so
that if I minimize if I make likelihood
small I can also regulate
I have learned in parameter distance and
not just in in likelihood value so
that's kind of like T these are kind of
the components that you need to get the
end-to-end results but if you if you
just have a neural network in there you
can always just do
stochastic gradient descent by just
exploding this very simple idea let me
skip this result and show you some NBA
data example so these are the NBA this
is of the NBA data from after year 2000
these are the heights of basketball
players which are a nice Gaussian around
2 meters and these are the number of
points per game scored by these players
if you do linear regression on this data
I'm not claiming that said I think to do
but if you were to do linear regression
to relate height to to number of points
per game you get this decreasing
negatively sloped curve if you so here
he's a nice tester I'm gonna do so I'm
going to truncate this data even further
so I'm going to look at players who
score at least eight points per game
which is this data now if I were to be
naive and say look okay so now I'm gonna
I'm doing truncation on the truncation
okay so if I was not even try to fit a
line I would get this line okay if I
don't take into account the fact that
I've already I've done truncation at 8
at least 8 points per game I get a
positively sloped and curve so if I do
list course regression but if I take
into account the fact that I truncated
all right points I will recover a
negatively sloping line okay which is
this is the benefit of thinking about
the fact that some truncation has
happened already in your data this is
certainly not the line you would fit if
you thought this is your data set but if
you think that these data set was
produced by truncating a different data
set then this line now makes sense
that's the maximum likelihood line okay
so I don't have too much time left but
let me discuss you know another type of
truncation statistics problem that
better fits
to the gender prediction story so in
that I have one minute right according
to my timeline so in this setting what
I'm doing is I'm gonna assume that there
were all these producers follows there
is an underlying distribution D that
samples images and their label but then
an unknown mechanism looks at the images
and decides whether or not to include
those images and their labels in my
training set okay so in particular for
example it could be that this Phi which
is an unknown to me looks at the Rays
the skin tone etc of that person and
depending on that decides whether or not
to post that image on the Internet okay
give it to me for training and so given
filtered data like that and given a and
that's an extra thing that we assume
given it a big test set that now is the
test that I am interested in so I have a
training set that is biased and also
have a test set that is not biased that
the test set has in are like images of
all sorts of people this is really the
these are really the images that other
I'm interested in labeling okay so I'm
given a biased but an labeled data set
and I'm given an unbiased but unlabeled
test set so what I wanna do is I want to
get a gender classifier that does well
in the unbiased distribution
why these guys don't you do important
sweetie you have to do some kind of
importance wedding the problem is now
you don't know the criteria based on
which the adversary decided whether or
not to include the images in your data
set so you don't so in this case you
don't know the filtering procedure so
the assumption is that you're given a
label and biased data set and unlabeled
an unbiased test set so you have to you
have to yeah so you have to learn this
filtering procedure and then do
likelihood based on that which is what
maximum likelihood setting we propose
does and it's an alternative to several
other domain adaptation approaches okay
here's one example and I'm going to
close with that so so so here we did the
following experiment we took images and
we looked and also a very good gender
classifier and we looked at the images
where the gender classifier fails okay
and here here's some images were the
gender class these are some hard male
images so this is where the really good
general classifier fails
these are easy male images where it's
successful these are hard female images
where it fails
these are easy female images where it
does not fail so it could look a very
good gender classifier and we looked at
where it fails and where it does not
fail and we create the dataset that
predominantly contains hard images and
contains very few easy images and we
gave that as a training set to a gender
classifier so now if you are naive about
it if you train on that bias dataset
were kind of like the rolls of film
male and females have been reversed you
slowly you start at the random guess and
you slowly become worse and worse and
worse in the unbiased data set because
you really learned if you learn a
flipped world well if you take into
account that there is a possible
truncation you can recover from that
late event so this is another thing I
want to talk about which is it's an
unsupervised learning problem where you
learn densities science yes but so this
is the this is the this is the probably
of correctness on the unbiased incorrect
yes you're stooping very badly compared
to the you're getting 55% correct yeah
we're slowly improving you know I
haven't saturated yet yes I have some we
have some results on unsupervised
learning there's learning densities
again are what we get is that we you
know get optimal rates for learning
gaussians and exponential families as a
function of the dimension of the data
but in summary yeah so you know the
mallanna work in the examples I gave you
no I don't know you know an approach of
using sensors that are carried
statistics to remove bias that enters
because your training set is not
representative of the conditions that
your algorithm will encounter in the
future how can you learn things that are
robust to the fact that there is a
selection bias in how you obtain your
dataset
okay so we have again a general
framework that works for neural nets is
based on STD but if you want to get em
to and guarantees we can provide those
for several old problems in statistics
in particular truncated linear
regression profit logistic and Gaussian
learning truncated gaussians
[Applause]
great suggestion can you go back to the
slide where you hit the basketball okay
goodbye why come no we are going I
remember the picture yeah yeah but there
is a simple yes which is I mean so
truncated linear regression is a no
problem in statistics that is unresolved
the X alone is symmetric and I would
like to inflict half the points below
there that's not gonna work because you
cannot reflect all of them you don't
know if you knew if you knew where the
line is that would work but you don't
know where the line is is this quarter
okay so I'm going to talk about the
regulation in fact of initial large
during a rate and this is joint work
with ventually I think who is still
technically at Stanford but he's going
to CMU for his job and also calling away
my students Stanford so Antoni MA
so I guess some we're going to talk
about recognization
however I guess the motivation at least
a low regional motivation of this
project was about faster algorithms so I
think two years ago I decided to join a
Facebook for a year and I was thinking
that I wanted to this design faster
algorithms empirically faster algorithms
for deep learning so you know probably
three years ago we were you know we with
a lot has and many other collaborators
we desired different kind of you know
theoretically faster algorithms for non
convex problems and I was thinking you
know maybe I should try some of these
four deep models
and then uh you know I tried a little
bit and they didn't work and then I
realized that somehow you know alibis me
no interesting area so actually if you
just want to help
faster chinning it's not that difficult
so what you only needs needs to do is to
use a smaller learning rate and that's
so easy where so this is Skippy wood
faster chaining and however the catch is
that the test accuracy wouldn't be as
good as as large anyway so here is a
plot I produced two years ago I couldn't
change the format because I don't have
access to the Facebook cluster anymore
so um so so let me pass this so the
orange ones are the training and test of
algorithm with initial linear 8.1 this
is kind o within student learning rate
point zero one point zero one is
considered to be like small in this case
and the green ones are the curves from
an algorithm with initial internal rate
on point one which is consist we are
lodged in your rectum and you can see
that in terms of training the dotted
line on the training curves and the
training performance is much better for
the photo for the small in Iroquois
however
the test we know performance and the
beginning of high performance of the
orange one the smaller near each one is
better but at the end of the day you
know after converging somehow the green
one piece the orange one and and if you
run it for long for longer you never see
that the orange one can catch up so um
so so somehow it just intrinsically
there's something happening here with
the large turning rate so large number
it helps us to regularize so that at the
end of the day we have better test
accuracy so this is not even about how
fast we converge in test accuracy this
is really about even a final accuracy
for the large and which one is much
better you know it's a little better
than on the smaller amount here you only
have one percent improvement but
depending on the data on the other side
in settings so here though the
improvement is only one percent just
because we are using all those data
parts kind of like architectures and
regularization so you cannot hope to how
can your much improvement but if you
don't have for example data augmentation
you see the gap is you know very big so
so this is you know in one sense no this
is really
because we see something new of a new
phenomenon here because the algorithm
can't recognize I guess you know now she
has taught boarding and many others have
talked about the AYGO the the
regularization effect of algorithms
however so this is really exciting you
know it bring us you know it opens up in
a lot of new research directions however
on the other hand the kind of law the
water is that you know the you know at
least though the bottleneck seems to be
that you know we don't understand a
regularization in fact of the algorithm
so that we don't know how to design by
the optimization algorithms so because
you know I may have found a better
optimization algorithms that ran faster
but you know but if I run it you know if
I don't understand regularization no
very likely outcome is that I run it on
a real data set and the German station
is not as good I guess so
I think you know I talked to you know
Leon at some point at Facebook about
this and Leon told me actually they have
tried this you know probably like 20
years ago
it's and found that second algorithm
comes in faster but the generalization
it's not that great so and also some so
this probably is not just graded by
myself like you know actually many
papers have reported it I was just kind
of slow on kind of reading those papers
that's why I discovered myself but
actually on they reported much earlier
on this in fact so so I guess the main
question I want to answer at least one
we can I try to partial answer and this
talk is that why large initial learning
rate can help generalization and
hopefully if you understand this we can
design by the optimization in the future
so and if you think about it it's not
that and your simple because the only
thing matters here is the initial
learning rate somehow so somehow because
the initial in rate makes a difference
somehow this analysis has to be somewhat
history
sensitive so the analysis of the
algorithm has to depend on what happens
at the beginning stage of the algorithm
and this means that you know is not that
easy to find a simplified setting that
you can see such a phenomenon for
example if you work with linear models
the linear models very likely as pretty
I think we are pretty almost sure that
the linear models wouldn't have this
property so first of all with
regularization is a strongly convex
problem
so the it doesn't really matter what
algorithm you use so there's no
regularization in fact and when there's
no regularization you know depending on
what loss you are using if you use
logistic loss I think not is and his
crisis papers have shown that you know
the iterate of the HUD doesn't depend on
actually in transition it only depends
on the the final running rate and if he
square loss I think you know large
roughly speaking I think the same thing
happens so so here because everything is
convex we kind of understand that each
race and I'm I'm very confident that
there there's no such phenomenon here
about the initial linear rate and often
the final on Android is what matters and
in sometimes initialization matters a
little bit because you know if you're
initializing the of subspace of them the
orthogonal space to your data then you
are not going to change anything there
so that's why instrumentation makes a
little bit and also another kind of a
lease typically for me to study this
problem was that um you cannot just you
know talk about the limiting behavior
for the same reason because what happens
is not you know what matters is not at
the end right so what your learning rate
you use so we cannot just take T to
infinity and studying the limiting
behavior of this stochastic process and
an NGK is also not you know really
helping here because mtk is pretty much
a linear model and with call
maximization in kernel space so it falls
into the first category so the work you
know we're doing here is that we found
authoritative institution and unfold and
the petula networks for this toilet
exclusion we show that actually on this
phenomenon occurs and the reason that
occurs is that
SGD learns various different patterns in
different orders with different learning
rate schedules so what the learning rate
schedules matters is that it learns
different patterns in different orders
and and because the others are
difference are different we will see
that this results in different
generalization performance at the end of
day so right so what other type of
patterns are we're talking about so
first of all you know I'm only going to
construct a kind of contrived the data
distribution for which we can
theoretically analyze this but at the
beginning I'm going to give the bigger
picture um you know what kind of like
constructions we are all working to do
so we're going to construct two patterns
so the first type of pattern is what we
call hard to generalize but easy to fit
patterns so these are you know in this
setting you know for example you know
you can think of as linear the separable
cause linearly classifiable patterns so
so this is you know simple too easy to
fit because you mean your linear model a
very simple architecture to fit such you
know on data but you at least requires
the same you know dimension above you
know data points to generalize so and
this is what we call hard to generalize
but easy to fit another type of pattern
in comparison or is easy to generalize
and hard to fit patterns so oh we are
going to use this concrete example where
you have for example a cluster data so
like I say the data points are clustered
into three groups and and these three
groups are in a line so and these are
possible examples and these are in the
middle we have negative examples and in
this case you cannot have a linear
separator to separate all the data
because the three clusters you know is
in a line so there's no linear
classifier classifier so that's why we
say it's hard to fit because you need at
least a two layer network to face such
data but because they are very tightly
clustered actually the generalization is
easy even though you need a truly
network because the only thing you need
to do is to pretty much memorize these
three points whether the three center of
the cluster and then basically after you
see three examples you can generalize
Ingle perfectly so to request a complex
model but very few samples to generalize
and these are the three or two type of
patterns we are going to talk about and
and we're going to show that learning
learning order in some sense matters
when the distribution have different
type of parties so here is a the how do
we construct a tall dispersion with
mixed patterns so so our data point
would have you know two subsets of
corners and the first upper corner
it's called x1 is of dimension on D and
the second subject bonus is also of
dimension D and so we're going to
construct three types of examples this
data set is going to be hello genius so
the first type of example has 20 percent
of mass and the strongest percent of
examples are of the form X 1 0 so the
second pattern doesn't exist and we only
have the first pattern and the first
pattern is generating is generated from
the first pattern the linearly
classifiable patterns and type 2
examples have you know also 20 percent
of mass and they are going to have you
know know who first other know first
pattern in the first set of chords and
the second set of corns will be
generated by the the second half pattern
clustered but not linearly separable
patches and the third type of examples
are the rest and they have both of the
packets so so what so the reason why we
care about this is that you know with
these hello Jeanie data set you can see
the learning order make a difference so
we're going to compare two algorithms so
the first algorithms is to kind of learn
the first type of pattern first and then
learn as the second pattern so basically
it first learns pattern one and what you
do with you know how do you learn
pattern one so basically type one
example and type three example have both
you know x1 in it so you can use all of
them to learn pattern one question
require them to be you want them to high
variance wait that's all so we do it Oh
what so what type 1 we do want them to
be a high bar n so I will talk about
exactly construction so basically you
can think of these two guys are some
half Gaussian so that you're the choirs
you know at least at the number of
samples to to to generalize right so so
access are the possible examples so I'm
yes so so there's a label associated
with them I think I'm I will be more
precise in the next act but just to
explain here real quick so by excellent
generated from pattern one I mean I join
you x1 under label together or from this
distribution the liberal use Incirlik
spoon and the label is also XY you know
technically in terms of notation yeah
yeah so so techno actually write x1
comma Y junk from packing what I have
one labels and they are coupled so x1
and x2 are generated from the same label
so you Commission a label and name
January x1 and x2 I'll be more clear
your next like so
alright so going back to the learning
orders so if you have such a you know
hello generated at that then if you
first if you want to learn the technique
1 first then what happens is that you
know you should use all the you know
examples which pattern one to learn
pattern one so basically you're going to
use type 1 and type 3 data where they
are explains in done so and and you find
the best linear fit right and then so we
can learn pattern 2 so let's say when we
learn pattern to we just use the rest of
the 20 percent of examples where they
are only our pattern to write so i gyum
to has a different order so what you do
is you learn pen and true first where
you find the best nonlinear fit to all
of those examples with pattern to right
so what examples have pattern to type
two and type three examples would have
pattern to and then you learn the rest
and now there are only 20% of examples
right left right because all the type 2
and have 3 examples already fit
perfectly so they are only 20% of
examples left
they are type 1 data so basically the
difference here is that in terms of
learning pattern 1 here in the first
algorithm we are using 80% of data with
the pattern 1 and the second case we are
only using 20% data because the the
route the rest of 6 percent was
to learn pattern to and they are faith
exactly and you will not you cannot use
them anymore so and and it supposed you
know this is what happens you know with
large memory that's smaller than rate
and you can see that there will be a
difference in terms of transition
because here the transition will be
better because you are using eighty
percent of the data and here the
transition would be worse because you
are using only 20% of the data and and
here I'm only talking about you know
learning pattern one learning pattern
two is always good because pattern 2 is
so easy to learn you only need three
examples to learn pattern to soap I
thought of the question so both of the
examples could learn pattern - very well
so basically what they're going to show
is that this large remember it plus a
meaning it's going to do a green one
example do exactly these two things and
a small learning rate throughout would
do the algorithm - so that's why I
wouldn't want an algorithm to our small
Android and large language will have a
difference in generalization performance
it just because they're Germanization
performance in the impacting one for
patching one are different because they
are learning from different number of
examples and the question so far so this
is just a high level plan I'll tell you
you know a little more about you know
how to week exactly construct this and
prove them so so I guess um also let's
just do a sanity check you know whether
we have any history dependency here in
terms of analysis and we do because the
use of logistic loss so basically what
happens is that when you slash generate
under needing so you're going to learn
pattern one first
and now after you use up all of this
data because we are using logistic loss
after sample is fit then because the
company is so high
under the greeting so small so you can
never use them really for anything else
Oh at least a in your work in a long
time you cannot use them unless the
confidence you know job come back so
pretty much you know after you're
learning some examples with largest loss
very well then you cannot use them
anymore
so that's why here we on after you learn
pattern one you cannot use you know on
those examples to learn pattern two and
the same thing happens here so that's
how the history dependency
could be I guess that's an appointment
that could be positive things to fix the
issue of this of this example right you
could have a constant learning rate and
do poisons jobs oh you know something
like that
yes you you see oh we have some
mitigation strategy which is very close
to JA pop so I guess some just um I'm
going to talk about mitigation strategy
at the end of the talk and here this is
a experiment that shows that artificial
data set
artificial real data set you can also
see this kind of phenomenon so you know
what we you know for artificial
synthetic artificial data set okay so
anyway so what we can prove is a we can
prove is a very tight case and here this
is a little bit more realistic case you
know it's still not a real data set but
it's a little bit more realistic so here
is how we generate the data set so you
want to kind of like them so so the idea
is that you know we want to say that in
a real data set you also have this
easier path in the heart pattern or like
oh this is true to have practice but we
couldn't find them at least we don't
know how to find them yet so what we did
is that we say in all the patterns in
the existing image they are type 1
pattern and we kind of just inject tab 2
pattern those kind of easy - easy to
generalize by hard to fit pattern so how
do we do that so basically we just say
we add this kind of watermark in the
middle of the Seafarer image and this is
the type 2 pattern so basically for
every class you have exactly two patches
and these two patches are just exactly
associated to that class and if you see
that two patterns you know exactly which
class they are and and you just inject
those kind of two patterns for all the
images in that class so you inject one
of the two patterns for all the images
in that class so basically we have two
patterns VI and VI prime for each class
I and we put v lv r prime in the
examples with class i and and and we
also you know kind of use the same kind
of like this type 1 type 2 type 3 kind
of construction 20% examples doesn't
have any patch and
20% of examples have only patched so you
don't have even any real image it's just
a patch in the middle and with like a
zero background and the 60% of examples
are mixed so and now we have a you know
tell us that and we can run experiments
and you know with last Android or
smaller and see what color patterns are
we are learning telnet plans are just a
no clean image yeah so and now we just
run this you know large memory and
smaller and rate example on this then we
want to see whether we learn the patch
first all we learned are in the real
image first right so we want to you know
so in this case we because we know what
the patterns are we can examine how was
the learning order of these patterns and
I'll ask you to ignore the green one
because this is actually a mitigation
strategy so let's just focus on a blue
and the right one so the blue one is
large Android class or needing and this
is the point where we are new ipok 30
and green one is just a smaller image
throughout I'm sorry I'm going to ask
you to ignore green and the right one is
smaller image throughout so and you can
see that when you look at the clean
accuracy the accuracy on the clean
examples the the blue one right so the
largest Android class annealing it does
get a no very good clean accuracy so and
but the clean accuracy for the small
Android one is not as good as the
cleaner Christopher Larson with one so
this is you know account to our works
you know explanation this is just
because you're on you are not using
enough samples to to learn the clean
pattern the pattern one with small and
rich and we can also see maybe this is
more informative if you look at the
patch accuracy so here what do we need
is that we just keep the patch to the to
the classifier and see what's accuracy
so this in in kind of like measuring how
much you learn how much you are using
pattern to the patch to classify and now
this is pretty kind of clear so when you
small remember it we are going to learn
a patch very very quickly so the pattern
to is learned you know very very quickly
in five o'clock however if you use large
learning rate you are not going to learn
pattern to and you are new so basically
with larger rate you
not just going to ignore the patch in
the middle because you somehow detect
that this is a various kind of practice
or you're the definition of clean
accuracy what is that you just invite
apply your model of random clean
examples without the right amount
without the modification and it's the
same unconditional distribution you want
yeah okay and then the watermark or the
patch accuracy is we just exclude you
know we just only have the martabak and
zero back wall back wall is just set to
zero yes and that's the versus images or
white or something yeah yeah so so I
think that if you can still classified
correctly that basically suggests that
you are learning a patch because you are
not given the image actually you only
give me the patch you're comparing it to
like oh oh I know in all what image
would give zero accuracy right I'm
saying so there's only one type of image
in the Patrick Casey
they are only there's only one type of
images so basically you just have like
20 images because for every class there
are ten classes every class they are two
type of two images you only have to
explain the images and I look at it
what's a quest easier so and and with
lodging where you I can ignore the patch
basically and we small in the raid you
are not going to you're going to learn
the patch very quickly so I think then
it would be linear a classifiable so I
needed the patches to be kind of on a
symmetric position so that the patches
cannot be linearly separable
this is also reflect this is also in our
construction as well
and I think we did try one patch and it
didn't work so so lodging we doesn't
learn the patches and the learning rate
learning the patches already hurts the
transition of clean images because with
the right curve you learn the patch very
early but you don't learn the second
cutting that well alright so I guess
probably I have
about ten minutes of less than ten
minutes six minutes
okay so then probably I would just go
very quickly about you know I'm not
saying too much up here actually so
basically this is just a the exact
construction so here I'm using the right
notation I'm going to generate X 1 Y
from the distribution P and diffusion P
passing one is gonna be just a linearly
separable to half Gaussian with some
margin the exactly it was probably don't
matter and a tap to our you know it
generate from you know the second
pattern which is kind of like this
so we construct this so that they are
not linearly separable and they are
clustering in terms of the directions so
and and and it's the type three it's
basically you you find a way to generate
it basically couple the label so that
joint to let you know X X Y and Y is
from P and X to Y is from Q basically
conditional label and in general X 1 X X
2 from the conditional distribution of
the data conditional label right so so
this is these are the second we can
proved on theorems and and I think the
important thing is that you know this is
not linearly classifiable so that's
that's why we have these two clusters
for label label one right so so that
they are not linearly classifiable so I
guess so I'll probably kind of like
escape the the the theorem statement the
statement is pretty much what I kind of
have told you I just make it a little
bit more kind of formal but still not
very formal because we I'm going to
sweep along things under the rock so I
guess the important thing is that we're
going to use some architecture that are
not exactly the the standard texture
because this is the only place where we
can prove it the only cases where we can
prove it so we need that the
architecture to work on x1 and x2
independently in some way and also the
algorithm we analyze is you know with
Gaussian noise so the noise you know
coming to play which I'm going to talk
about in a moment and then we can prove
that I've ridden one Larson rate plus a
medium can work an algorithm to doesn't
work even happens not too much time like
let me not get get into details here so
I guess um I want
about the basic intuitions a little bit
because I think that's probably the most
interesting thing here so in analysis
when we have smaller rate what we do is
basically just say this is kind of an TK
and and with n TK you can analyze the
convergence you know how fast it
converges in so on and so forth
we need to do a little more work on you
know on top of n TK to exactly
characterizing on which patterns we
learn and what's interesting is about
Larsson with Y with Larsson which you
are not going to look you are not going
to learn pattern to with large enumerate
and the reason is the following so when
you use large generate the noise is very
big because you know we have largely we
supposed to have the same amount of toys
Larson in redwood course so suppose you
have the same amount of noise ingredient
then large number it corresponds to
effectively larger amount of noise in
the iterate and that means that the
weights change a lot so and when wastes
change allowed and notice it's big so
what happens is that if you look at your
model on the on the second type of
pattern right it's kind of like a
cluster pattern so then actually your
model cannot do really a full powerful
to learn Network actually your model can
only be paved like a linear model with a
noisy speak so the reason is that
suppose you have a vector W and this w
is not going to separate this clusters
so suppose this w is kind of like all
the data points is on one side of the W
so that means that your activation
pattern it's going to be all the same
for the three type of examples or Z
Zeman's data on Z and Z plus theta so
basically even though you have a row of
W transpose X actually the value is not
doing a much work the rail you is always
giving you those fakes fixed sign for
all the pattern two examples if you
restate things
forget the choice of learning rate just
give me in the first you know twenty
percent of time steps examples from
better to in the last 80 percent
examples are better than one so then
you're saying no matter what any
algorithm is going to do that because it
will
no I know and I what I meant is the
learning rate doesn't really matter in
that case yeah you are right so that the
learning rate doesn't matter in that
case and but we couldn't prove that no a
group whatever you can do all algorithm
will be bad we can only prove that
certain algorithm will be back because
your argument has to kind of used up the
first back of examples will not help you
if you just give me first 20% yeah first
to an end
yep so so but the hard part is that yes
that I agree under and it's not that
hard to show that the the hard part is
that to show the learning rate kinds you
know can give you the right order right
large son will give you the right order
and small and really keep use the
different order so that's a that's the
technical difficulty all right so I'm
here at basic I'm trying to say that you
know if you still are journey where you
are not gonna learn pattern - even
though you are given pattern - in
algorithm and the reason is that the
waste is too big and the waist is too
random so that you never behave as a
nonlinear function so so it's basically
the new room it's always kind of like a
linear function so the neuro satisfies
something like this you know you look at
these two points and you average them
and it's actually equal to the points in
the middle so you always have a linear
function so that's kind of why you
cannot learn these kind of patterns
because they are not linearly separable
and and and and only when you a new
learning rate you are going to reduce
the noise level so that you can see some
W that can be concrete hyperplane that
is in between this you know example
clusters so that you can have a
nonlinear model on this data solution
and that's the key intuition so I guess
I'll skip some of the technical
intuitions I guess this is probably
recorded if you're interesting so I
guess let me talk a little bit about the
medication strategy so our series
suggests that if you use large neural
rate you inject all of nodes in the
activation pattern and that prevents us
to learn they're easy to generalize
patterns because if you have a lot of
noise in activation pattern you behaves
like a linear model and and and we try
to see whether this can
us too kind of like a design of
mitigation strategy and the natural
medication strategy is just that you add
noise is improve activation so which is
kind of like job hot so and so now we
can talk about the green one which is
basically a small in rate plus noise
right so now we have small in rate but
we use noise to prevent us to learn the
various artificial pattern so now you
can see that the green one with noise
wouldn't learn the activation the
artificial pattern with even smaller in
a rich and and you'll need the you know
I think here your new the noise level
and then you can learn on the at the
pattern so that you can get a little
better accuracy so so this is a indeed
of mitigation strategy and also we tried
this on clean data with without
artificial patch and actually it still
helps improve the accuracy when you when
you have a small and rich so basically
here's the experiment on see part ten
with some you know white rice 1916
so I guess so this and this are the
baselines so large and rich plus a
meaning
that's ninety percent and small and rate
we have eighty four percent so so
there's a six percent gap between large
and small on your rate and if we use
small Android class reactivation noise
we can recover that gap by pretty much
most of the that gap um by the way this
numbers are you know not that high just
because we don't have the documentation
here so that we can see the gap between
these two are six percent if you have
the competition then the gap in a large
and small in the rate is probably 2 or
2% or something like that yeah so okay
so I guess just to wrap up quickly so
the main message is that lots and we
learn it's hard to generalize easy to
fake pattern and small and really learn
it's easy to generalize and hard to fake
pattern and orders to learning of or
learning these patterns do matter with
logistic loss and that guy's the open
questions are that how do we identify
these patterns in real data we don't
know how to do it yet we we try to in
jacket you know inject artificial
patterns but we don't know how to add
by these patterns in real data and how
do we make the results more general
instead of only on our control of the
toy examples this example is really toy
so you know we'll have an idea is how to
prove that so and finally the last slide
I have to share some of my hair is my
personal broader outlook about
algorithmic regularization so I guess
some good you know this work is kind of
under the broader kind of scope of
algorithmic rotation and at least you
know maybe this just me like us we could
improve in a stronger results but it
sounds like understanding algorithm
acquisition is very challenging because
even on this toy examples we need to
spend like for the pages of 50 pages to
prove everything and also it's not clear
for this coil cases what complex measure
the algorithm is regulating so it's
really kind of complicated so so in some
sense I'd like to also kind of like home
you know at least just to to think about
you know one other possible shortcut to
kind of like a deal with these kind of
things like you know maybe you know
suppose I'm being optimist pessimistic
maybe one thing you know we couldn't
even make very very you know big
progress in terms of understanding
algorithmic requisition in a near future
but it could be that another rod which
is a little bit cheating but easier is
that you can say we can find
experiencers that can subsume the
algorithmic regularization at least
empirically so that so we design you
know Express regressors and we run the
Express rack risers you know on a real
data set and we can see we hope to see
that you don't have to use the algorithm
to recognize and now these at least
solve the optimization issue because now
with this record Iser I can safely
design faster algorithm I have the
separation of concern I only have to
care about I have a faster algorithm but
I don't have to think about you know
whether my regularization is not found
out from my algorithm and we have seen
some you know initial preliminary
promising signs from using a some of
this data dependent regularization so
these are organizations which doesn't
only depend on
of the parameters but also depends on
other qualities in the network for
example activations and other six so and
and also the final point I'd like to
make is that generally I suspect that
the hello geniality of the data sets are
something that is important so we can
see here the interesting phenomenon
occurs when we have her genius leader
set and also I suspect that you know in
general problem when you have
heterogeneity in a data set the the
practical improvements are also somewhat
easier
I suspect that probably standard data
size you know when everything is
designed so nicely so the less that's
already well tuned for a great
memorization so it's very hard to see
whether Express regressors can improve
the accuracy for example you know when
there are imbalanced assess we found
that Express memorization actually could
help a lot in terms of practical
performance we have this paper that have
very very has very very simple theory
like the theory is kind of as easy as
homework questions for for class but the
empirical performance is it's much
better than the previous say the part I
guess so and that's all I want to say
thank you
[Applause]
you